varias aldeas palestinas en el área de
nabús soy lucen hoy sus calles desiertas
y con el temor de sus habitantes tras
las violentas agresiones de colonos
israelíes que siguieron a la muerte de
dos israelíes en un ataque palestino en
jugára con cuchillos o de palos piedras
y hasta armas de fuego cientos de
colonos irrumpieron en la noche del
domingo al grito de venganza
principalmente en jugar pero también en
otras aldeas como Bullying y satara
precisamente en esta última un palestino
de 37 años murió luego de que colonos le
dispararan en el abdomen además en la
media luna roja Palestina reportó 390
heridos y según el recuento de medios
locales al menos 35 viviendas quedaron
totalmente destruidas otras 40
parcialmente dañadas y un centenar de
vehículos fueron incendiados Así mismo
testigos y organizaciones de Derechos
Humanos denunciaron la no intervención
de las fuerzas israelíes para frenar las
agresiones de hecho solo ocho personas
fueron detenidas y seis ya fueron
liberadas el presidente Isaac Soccer fue
el único alto cargo israelí que condenó
la violencia de los del lado del Primer
Ministro benjamine taniaju este se
limitó a pedir que no se tome la
justicia por mano propia mientras que es
Vica foguel parlamentario de la
coalición de extrema derecha apoyó la
agresión de los colonos y dijo que
quiere ver jugar cerrada y quemada en
este escenario el gobierno israelí ha
desplegado más soldados e impuesto tres
días de bloqueo en los accesos anablus
en parte para encontrar al atacante de
palestino de los dos jóvenes israelíes
medidas que no permiten vislumbrar la
desescalada a la que se comprometieron a
hacer en Jordania funcionarios israelíes
y palestinos